-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're watching at home,
thank you.
Well, guys, everyone was
talking about this.
Today, Facebook and Instagram
were hit by a massive outage
and stopped working for
millions of users.
Yeah. It was amazing.
[ Audience boos ]
Yeah. Get it out.
Get it out, yeah.
-Wow.
-Facebook was
only down for a day,
and in that short time,
everyone got the vaccine.
Isn't that amazing?
Amazing.
Amazing how that happened.
I don't know.
Yes, Facebook's
entire site crashed.
They were like, "Oh, my God.
This is the best press we've
had in months!"
Meanwhile, people
who couldn't use Instagram
spent the day posting their
weekend pumpkin-patch
selfies on LinkedIn.
That's not good.
No one cares. You know.
"Isn't he cute?"
"Well, kind of.
He's 24 now, isn't he?
"Yeah, but he still likes --"
-"He's still cute."
-Speaking of Facebook,
on "Meet the Press" yesterday,
a journalist
who has been covering
the social-media company
was on the show,
but he was wearing
a very interesting accessory.
Take a look at this.
-So, joining for me for more on
all of this is Jeff Horwitz.
He's one of
"The Wall Street Journal"
reporters who's been
reporting on Facebook
under their umbrella
"Facebook Files."
-Yeah.
Chuck Todd was like,
"And right now,
Zooming in from his kid's karate
tournament is Jeff Horwitz.
Jeff."
Well, this is exciting.
It was just announced that,
next week,
90-year-old legendary actor
William Shatner,
also known as Captain Kirk,
will travel to space
aboard Jeff Bezos'
Blue Origin rocket.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
You can tell Elon Musk
is jealous of Bezos' idea,
'cause he just yelled,
"Get me Betty White on Line 2!
Rose, you're going to space."
I love how Elon Musk sounds like
Ralph Kramden now.
-Rose! To the moon!
-To the moon, Rose!
Meanwhile, I heard about another
new option for space travel --
I don't know if you saw this --
that's now available.
Watch this. This is real.
-Instead of riding a rocket,
this is a slow ride to
the edge of space
inside a pressurized capsule
hanging beneath
a massive helium balloon.
The view will be spectacular
inside a first-class cabin
complete with massive windows,
Wi-Fi, even a bar and restroom.
-A helium balloon, yeah.
Sounds all well and good
until there is a leak,
and you're like...
[ High-pitched ]
"Okay, I'm freaking out.
Mayday, mayday!
Houston, we have a problem!
Please -- No, no!
Alvin! Alvin!"
[ Normal voice ] I actually hope
they send Shatner
on the balloon so
it will feel like
a live-action remake of "Up."
-Oh!
-Yeah.
I think that'd be cool.
Some sports news.
Last night was Tom Brady's big
return to New England.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great game.
Brady faced his old coach,
Bill Belichick.
And you can tell
the two men still have
a lot of love for each other.
Check out how long
they hugged after the game.
-Good game.
-Well, well, there it is. Okay.
-Can we throw a timer
on that hug?
-Well, well, there it is. Okay.
-Wow. I've had longer hugs
with strangers on the bus.
It's like...
Well, this is interesting.
The future royalties from
the Folgers jingle,
"The Best Part of Wakin' Up"
are being sold at auction.
-Ah! Correction, Jimmy.
They were being sold at auction.
The Roots all pooled
our money together
and snapped that jingle up
immediately.
And now we just wait
for the money to roll in.
-Whoa! You guys own
the Folgers jingle?
-♪ The best part of buying it ♪
♪ Is getting paid to say
these words ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How much money
do you get for that?
-♪ We just made 11 cents ♪
♪ Now we made 11 more ♪
-Yeah. Hmm.
It doesn't seem like very much.
-♪ The key is to sing
this tune ♪
♪ To everything we say ♪
-Gotcha, gotcha.
So, how much did you have to bid
to win the royalties?
-♪ We dropped 60,000 bucks ♪
♪ Plus tickets to our show ♪
-Oh. Let's see. $60,000.
Okay, so in order to break even,
you need to sing that song --
-♪ 5,450 times ♪
♪ Followed by four more ♪
-Alright, yeah, guys,
this doesn't seem like
a very smart investment.
-♪ Regret it deeply
to our core ♪
♪ It was a huge mistake ♪
-Well...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, in that case...
♪ I'm glad I could
help you out ♪
♪ Now let's move on
with the show ♪
-That will be --
that will be 11 cents, Jimmy.
-[ Chuckles ]
You're not serious, right?
-♪ Pay the 11 cents ♪
♪ Or we'll see you in court,
mother[bleep] ♪
-Are you kidding me?
-That is rude!
-That's the original lyrics
to the jingle?
to the song?
-We just got fined $60,000.
-Oh, my God.
-They'll never make
that money back.
-I guess there's more than
Folgers in your cup.
-Yeah.
Hey, everyone,
I saw that two scientists
were just awarded the
Nobel Prize in medicine
for discovering the receptors
that let humans feel
temperature and touch.
Meanwhile, the scientists who
saved millions of lives
by creating the COVID vaccine
were like, "Yeah."
That deserves a Nobel Prize.
The stove's hot.
Way to go, guys. Yeah."
But get this.
Their research
did find one human
without the capacity to feel.
Here he is.
-Good game.
-Well, well, there it is. Okay.
-Ice. Ice.
20 years they worked together.
Yeah.
Some entertainment news.
This is amazing.
"Squid Game" is now on track
to be Netflix's
most-watched show ever.
They will be on
our show this week.
-Whoa!
-That's right.
It's a terrifying
dystopian drama.
Now other TV networks
want to get in on the action,
and I already saw an ad
for a spin-off.
Watch this.
-From the creators of
"Squid Game"
comes a new
and horrifying series
on Nickelodeon.
"Squidward Game."
-Whoa! I've never played
this game before.
What's it called?
-It's called...
[ Distorted ]
"Sign in blood or Patrick dies!"
-"Squidward Game."
-I can't do it.
I can't do it, Squidward.
-Catch it after "Paw Patrol."
-Yeah, it's on after.
It's on after "Paw Patrol."
You get that out of the way.
And, finally, an Ohio judge
ruled that a man
wasn't allowed to sue his wife
after he tripped over her shoes
and fell down the stairs.
On the bright side,
the judge did rule in favor of
putting a camera in their car
for the ride home from court.